[Music]
this morning the Revolutionary a new
book about Samuel Adams by Pulitzer
Prize winner Stacy Schiff perhaps no
member of the American Revolution is
less understood than the man who
Jefferson called the leader of it part
of that's because Samuel Adams didn't
want to be remembered part of that's
because of what we've turned him into a
hothead a brand of beer the truth
thankfully is far more interesting as we
found out at the Old South Meeting House
on the Freedom Trail in Boston
I mean what brought me to this book in
large part was how little we knew about
him we all recognized the name we know
so little about him first things first
please try not to call him Sam his
enemies later referred him as Sam Adams
in a somewhat derogatory way so when
he's written off by 19th century
historians he tends to become that
incendiary Sam Adams so it's a little
bit of a term of disrespect I think
Sam was first used as a brush-off later
in our times a beer hey buddy you want a
Sam Adams in fact Samuel Adams Legacy is
far more consequential than the portrait
on the front of a bottle Jefferson said
he was the most important part of the
Revolution did I get that right you did
it's he says he's basically if the
revolution if there had been a leader it
was that man was Samuel Adams and he
calls him the earliest the most active
and the most persevering Patriot this
was his place
this was where he was several times the
man of the hour exactly Stacy Schiff
arrived at Samuel Adams after a career
spent documenting fascinating lives
Vladimir nabokov's wife Ben Franklin
Cleopatra and The Witches of Salem her
latest subject seemed like Destiny
you're from Adams Massachusetts I mean
come on I'm from Adams Massachusetts yes
I am which some people I think think was
named for John but was in fact named for
Samuel and that and that was part of the
embarrassment of this book I had written
there's a cameo of Samuel Adams in my
Ben Franklin book and at one point it
occurred to me that I knew
embarrassingly little about this person
about whom I had written and that it was
even more embarrassing because in fact
yes I am from Adams Massachusetts Samuel
Adams was born into wealth but after the
British dissolved a land bank his father
had established to help lend money to
colonists the family was ruined for the
first 40 Years of his life many
considered Samuel Adams a failure until
the man met the moments starting with
the imposition of the Stamp Act in 1765
to the Boston Massacre Adams operated
behind the scenes to rile up the
citizenry most influentially as a
newspaper opinion writer almost always
using assumed names Adams was a master
manipulator of the news
I would say master propagandist is
probably that yes the two words that
best characterize him I mean he does
that you probably see that best after
the Boston Massacre the trials have
taken place the British soldiers who had
fired on civilians are tried all but two
of them are are found to be innocent and
Adams Then goes to the press and
relitigates the entire case making
everyone seem guilty and in fact
convincingly so that's Sam Adams yes
that's Sam Adams and whatever's
happening here tonight he's the one man
who holds the key to the situation the
Boston Massacre eventually led to the
Boston Tea Party
reenacted here in 1953 for the CBS
series you are there
if we fail here whole Revolution all
that we've planned for years will die
three ships in the harbor three teams of
men we don't know precisely who they are
they are lightly disguised as Native
Americans some of them better disguise
than others the destruction of tens of
millions of dollars in British goods
puppet Mastered by Adams and others is
still recreated every 15 minutes in
Boston Harbor today but when you're
fomenting a revolution sometimes you
need practice this is Revolution
practice this is what I think we're
watching here yeah yeah that was a good
that was a good throw yeah it was wow
another good one why was he able to piss
people off so magnificently
I think there's a tenacity there which
which may come from the I don't care
what people think of me school he's like
a cartoon character constantly sort of
running circles around around Crown
officials and I think there's a certain
amount of creativity to that I mean he
really there was no loophole that he
cannot dive through add to that the
British appeared often to rule through a
combination of fickleness and
inattention is it just the way our
American history is written or were the
British really that moronic
in in how they tried to manage all this
it just seemed like one blunder after
another the number of missteps the
number of moments at which at ings
traction because there has been British
overreach or British tone deafness is
extraordinary and what's really what's
really striking is the level of
ignorance in Great Britain although the
inability to either take the colony
seriously or to even place them on a map
I mean most people didn't know if Boston
was in the West Indies or the East
Indies I mean there was just tremendous
lack of knowledge of what they were
dealing with
shifts the Revolutionary gets deeply
into details including Adam's love-hate
relationship with John Hancock whom
atoms regarded as far too consume with
clothes and fame
and it gets into what happened after the
revolution when Adams less successfully
served as lieutenant governor and then
governor of Massachusetts
of power didn't really suit Samuel Adams
nor did any interest in hegeography he
didn't really leave his papers he didn't
write an autobiography it's it it's
almost like he didn't care John Adams at
several junctures says to him could you
please collect your papers no one will
be able to understand the revolution
without your papers those are two
decades of essential writing you know
you really need to put them together
everyone will be interested and Adams
for whatever reason never picks up on it
he really leaves the history to others
and we know what happens when you leave
the history to others other people's
versions creep in you said he made
almost as much trouble for historians as
he did for the British
I think it's really hard to get a sense
of him there's all of this tremendous
18th century testimony to how Central
and how vital he is every Founding
Father basically says he's in the
Vanguard and then he's off the radar and
find putting him back in the picture
requires a certain amount of effort
we did this interview a stone's throw
from where I used to live right wow I
lived in Boston for four years and I I
learned so much that I didn't know I
mean so many people don't know yeah
there's so many founding fathers like
that you know Benjamin rushed my
favorite is he Samuel Adams you know
your favorite I don't I don't know that
I have one but I don't have to think a
lot here yeah